[Musique]
merci bonsoir
est-ce que ça va d'accord alors comme il
a dit moi je suis à libérer premier pour
ceux qui comprennent pas beau les ports
et ça veut dire un film pour ceux qui ne
comprennent pas bruno france est aussi
là un film ça veut dire quelqu'un qui
n'a pas du bon pied alors moi je suis né
dans une famille modeste une grande
famille africaine de 14 enfants
je suis le troisième de mon père est le
deuxième de ma mère et à l'âge de trois
mois j'ai eu la chance de contracter une
maladie que vous connaissez tous la
poliomyélite
je suis allé à l'école à l'âge de 10 ans
avec des enfants qui avaient 6 7 1 si je
vous dis que j'ai eu la chance de
contracter cette sale maladie
c'est justement pour vous dire qu'il a
fallu que je sois victimes de cette
maladie pour être ce que je suis
aujourd'hui alors à l'école c'était
difficile parce que c'était les années
polio du 1900 je dirais à 60 à 114
c'était les années polio et les enfants
car ils me voyaient ramper parce que je
rentrais à terre je ne pouvais même pas
marcher avec les békés à l'époque il
avait peur de moi donc à l'école j'étais
rejeté parce que les enfants avaient
peur mes camarades avaient peur du mois
et c'est danser
l'ambiance je suis rincé jusqu'au
collège et au collège une autre
dimension du région matane est parce qu
avec des camarades de classe qui à
chaque fois parce que nous organisions à
l'époque des compétitions un tel
établissement des compétitions
culturelles et mes camarades de classe
ne voulais pas qu'ils les accompagnent
parce que j'étais gênant pour eux
puisque justement à ces soirées là on
échangeait entre copains copines et moi
si je suis là je vais les gêner parce
que ils pourront pas justement à l'eesi
madrague et leurs copines et avec les ti
oc enfin les camarades si c'était pareil
- avec l'adolescent je voulais aussi
comme les jeunes de mon âge mais draguer
les filles et quand je les réserve quand
c'est le métier il est audacieux ce
monsieur
donc c'est dans cette ambiance je suis
resté une ambiance village de filtration
et un jour je me suis dit si ta vie n'a
pas de sens c'est très simple donne un
sens à ta vie quand tu as des défauts il
faut les convertir en qualité et ce qui
m'a aidé bien c'est une émission
diffusée sur une radio de la place une
radio fm à l'époque nous étions dans les
années je dirais 94 95 et ils
diffusaient comme on appelle ça une
musique afro-américaine et je me suis
dit tiens moi je peux aussi faire la
même chose c'est à l'europe à l'époque
et j'ai commencé à faire le rap et comme
nous étions disons le premier rappeur du
burkina parce qu'elle n'avait pas j'ai
commencé à être aimés entre griffe parce
que tous ceux qui meurent et jetait pour
masser revenu vers moi parce que dès
lors je commençais à être une toute
petite célébrité dans le monde je dirais
artistique et c'est comme ça que ça a
commencé et je me suis dit tiens si
parle on peut faire quelque chose je
veux organiser aussi le milieu de
personnes vivant avec un handicap en
créant justement des associations
pour la défense de ces personnes là et
dès lors on a passé un tram y a créé des
groupuscules pour une somme à défendre
la cause des personnes vivant avec un
handicap ici au burkina faso et comme
j'étais à chaque fois puisque pour le
faire le rap il faut être bien habillé
avec le basket et où j'étais vraiment
très bien a dit à l'époque
à elles seules ont commencé à changer
dans ma famille mes mains on me cacher
quand j'étais petit enfin les visiteurs
ont mérité les passantes il faut rester
dans la chambre et maintenant par des
visiteurs même si un super la maison on
me les charges on m'appelle retient il
faut binaire famille intel est la leur
et gt et r en tant qu il appelait le
rechercher et c'est comme ça ça
commençait vraiment à changer pour moi
pour ma famille et pour les autres
personnes vivant avec handicap
quand les politiciens venez nous voir
ils nous disent il faut voter tu as une
personne handicapée mais son pilote un
dans l'urne c'est important qu'on peut
tout le monde on ne va pas dire comme
c'est une personne handicapée qui l'a
mise les dents c'est ce à quoi je compte
sur tout le monde mais quand il s'agit
de travailler après on nous dit comme
vous êtes comme ça là c'est compliqué
nous allègrement nous sommes des hommes
comme tout le monde
c'est pour cela je parle d'inclusion
parce que nous personnes vivant avec
handicap nous sommes un maillon de la
chaîne
et si à un moment de la chaîne qui donne
pas c'est sûr que la chaîne va pardonner
quand vous avez un billet de 5000 francs
qu'il soit sale quant à déchirer sa
valeur de 5000 francs ne change pas on
vous dira pas consacrer à temps ses 5500
on vous dit lapointe qu'on se déchire et
ses 2500 5000 ses 5000 ce qui traduit ce
si un homme est un homme que tu sois
aveugle est fuir ou soul mais sa valeur
intrinsèque dormait change pas on est
d'accord
comme c'est justement pour dire que
seule la lutte libère pour me le dit moi
je vis avec un handicap jamais dit que
je suis une personne à part entière mais
j'ai souvent l'impression d'être une
personne entière
pas c'est le regard des autres mine de
rien ou les personnes handicapées nous
avons beaucoup beaucoup de dépenses à
faire même dans la vie quand moi je veux
me déplacer il faut que j'achète mes
béquilles quand je vais me déplacer en
moto il faut que moi j'achète la moto
atterri et que cela modifie que j'ai
l'adapt à ma situation de handicap
c'est encore des dépenses quand je veux
construire ma maison il faut que j'ai la
tête à ma situation de handicap
c'est plus de dépenses mais quand il
s'agit de travers ou les spas travail il
ya un problème ce coup cela j'interpelle
les décideurs j'interpelle les
politiques à ce qu'il prenne en compte
les personnes vivant avec handicap et le
problème que nous rencontrons également
parce que quand vous décidez vous prenez
des arrêtés vous signer des décrets en
faveur des personnes handicapées sans
les consulter
vous ne vivez pas la situation de
handicap seule la personne handicapée
elle même prenait ce besoin parce qu'il
est le seul à vivre son handicap
moi personnellement j'ai eu la chance
parce que j'ai jamais marché puisque la
polio m'a pris quand j'avais trois mois
mais pour quelqu'un qui a marché qui
après contractent la maladie
j'imagine que c'est c'est un peu triste
quand même et on nous force à jouer aux
équilibristes parce qu'on veut qu'on se
déplace comme tout le monde qu'on se met
debout
l'endroit m'a forcée voilà pourquoi je
m'achète des béquilles parce que moi a
pas de pattes je suis plus rapide sans
les beti voilà donc c'est les boutiques
murale attise parce que je me dis la vie
de 29 ans comme ça on devait être comme
les animaux parce que moi quand je vois
les animaux il joue pas aux dés quéribus
et ce n'est pas pour marcher sur deux
pattes dans moi je disais que c'était
normal pour moi de me déplacer comme ça
et je suis plus à l'aise
c'est pour cela j'ai dit c'est une
chance pour moi nous personnes vivant
avec un handicap au burkina faso nous
sommes 10 % de la population aucune
abeille et 10% ce n'est pas négligeable
si nous voulons avancer on ne peut pas
avancer sans ce type où ça parce que
nous sommes tous autant que nous sommes
des fils et des filles de ce pays
c'est tout cela j'interpelle tout le
monde pour une relecture et une
reconsidération des personnes vivant
avec un handicap et des têtes ceci en
leur faveur
parce que c'est ensemble vraiment que
nous allons y arriver et charges ou
quand je sors de ma maison je veux
toujours chaud que positivement les gens
pour le dire
moi j'ai un slogan au lieu de faire
pitié je veux faire rêver je veux que
les gens comprennent que le handicap
n'est pas une fatalité
c'est un défi à relever le pour relever
ces défis nous avons besoin d'édifices
et les défis de ce pays ensemble avec
nos différences nous allons y arriver
donc encore une fois de plus
j'interpelle les uns et les autres à
soutenir la personne vivant avec un
handicap parce que personne n'a souhaité
le handicap personnes
donc de grâce encore une fois s'il vous
plaît aidez nous à sortir justement de
cette situation de handicap tant à
apprendre je le dis et je le répète le
handicap n'est pas une fatalité
c'est un défi à relever et ensemble nous
allons y arriver
je vous remercie